kyle hendricks technically not homegrown
although he was traded early on
in his career actually involved in a
deal with ryan dempster damn happy
birthday yesterday
back in 2012 those two were involved in
a trade with texas here's the numbers
for hendricks seven and a half era and
the last three starts for him
against the dodgers have not produced
good results as well
kyle hendricks matching up with mookie
betts
and he connects to the left side a
little bobble it's short by baez
and betts is aboard to start the day
he's almost hit too much right at him
you know infielders love to get a little
rhythm
movement he got a little stationary
there and it pulled up in the club short
stop on the other side
corey seeger seeger's aggressive he goes
after the second pitch as well
and the cubs turn two with ease
we'll see what the rest of the game goes
this boat's well i think he's attacking
the bottom of the zone with
late movement two gone and the third
baseman turner
turner on the ground it's all biased
bubbles again this time
recovers with plenty of time to spare
to make the third out and now clayton
kershaw to begin the day for los angeles
with a 209 earned run average it's even
better in his last
five one zero nine is the mark coming
off the start against cincinnati where
he stopped a little slump for the ball
club this is the matchup to keep an eye
on chris
bryant has been on a tear that's a fair
ball
and that's going to roll up into the
seats for two a ground rule double
for chris bryant rizzo's career numbers
against kershaw are impressive nine for
28 three homers three doubles
kershaw goes with the curve ball it's a
fair ball
and that's gonna score bryant first run
of the game for the cubs anthony rizzo
delivers again against hershaw
it's one nothing north siders that's why
he's
third against the left-hand hitter
lieutenant pitcher nice
nice job with breaking ball another ball
is hard to keep fair scotty
now it's matt duffy duffy on the ground
past seeger and that's going to move
everyone up the station
bags are full of cubs on the base hit
for duffy now pitching in a stressful
bottom of the first here against david
body
and that is soars to left david bodie
off the ivy that's gonna score a couple
for chicago here comes a third to clear
the bases
he's in there david bode with a
three-run double to break this thing
open in the first
rizzo baez and duffy come on down
high heater once you get on the high
heater get on top of it
threw it right where he wanted to throw
it should pull his hands inside this and
get on top of it
that's a pretty swing one thing as an
outfielder you know you can't catch a
ball you got to get as far
off the fence as you can because the
caramel shouldn't go by
eight hitter el dimaro vargas first
start of the season
just called up from the alternate site
and he got him and marisnick makes it to
second
a strikeout and a swipe back
and hendricks goes after the first pitch
and lobs it to
left center there's taylor for out
number three
and now the one-two got him first
strikeout of the day for hendricks
lux chip shot and it's gonna be a tough
play and no play for baez he'll eat it
infield knock for gavin lux and muncies
to second
eighth place hitter austin barnes
that's a big pitch big inning from kyle
hendricks
works around a hit by pitch and a base
hit will kershaw be back on the mound in
the second
for the dodgers after a troublesome
first
one inning from clayton kershaw 39
pitches
gives up four runs in the first for just
the second time in his career and his
day
is done earlier than anticipated i just
don't think dave robert's comfortable
running back out there it's cold it's
windy
uh it's early in the season he just
threw on let's say 40 pitches
first team that's a lot of wear and tear
on arm well dennis santana takes over
two down here's baez baez sends the
first pitch to deep center and it's not
deep enough
taylor about five feet in front of the
track
for the catch and an end to the second
is the shift against bets
bets on the ground gets through wide
open right side
and a base hit for mookie bets a one out
hitter
that's a board for the dodgers in the
third
turner entering today four for eighteen
two homer's career against
hendricks he'll take the free pass bets
toseki
two on two outs cleanup hitter max
muncie on the way
muncie strikes out big
fourth k for kyle hendricks hildemara
vargas
follows in the eighth spot vargas sends
one to
center the floater is successful and
mariznick's hustling the third and in
there
two out not for the eight hitter runners
on the corners for chicago threatening
again
that one skips away and that's gonna
score another run for the cubs
and here comes vargas and he's in on the
wild pitch
for two six nothing chicago we talked
about the fastball and the dirt
spike being the hardest one for a
catcher earlier here's another one
just a you know 50 foot spike catchers
get caught
so much because they're not ever
expecting a fast ball to be spiked
and they're ready for a breaking ball
spike or a change up
he's got good late life yeah he does
pollock can't handle it and that's the
fifth strikeout for kyle hendricks
so far this season and rios connects it
to first
little toss to hendricks covering the
bag what a bounce-back performance so
far
from the professor third pitcher of the
day for the dodgers is jimmy nelson
contreras down on strikes payoff to
rizzo
in there that looked good from jimmy
nelson spotting the fastball
all those short stops and justin turner
over to short there he is javi baez how
much is he worth
rizzo with the step on the base pretty
much
yeah kyle hendricks still working in the
sixth then why not he's been efficient
now it works up in the zone i mean
switching up locations
speeds putting on a show two gone one on
and it's gavin lux check swing
fancy flip el
at shortstop he's the magician that's
the professor
the cubs getting it done jake mariznick
hilton marrow vargas and the pitcher
spot
due up here in the sixth jake mariznick
solid contact to left
forget about it jake mariznick big dude
muscles up
solo shot his third of the season seven
nothing
cubbies i think the wrist is all right
huh yeah did you see rizzo
how's that wrist
that is blasted off the bat of k bear
ruiz
and he's got his first home run
just called up today first pitch he
loves it how awesome is this
let me teach you a little something
about what we do at wrigley
seeker down away full extension
[Applause]
turner on the ground buys another chance
and this time
gets it done the ball will find you
you can take that into game two